we have a business proposition for you
I mean it's the worst fate Krang who
ever seen she's just using the technique
for what the technique oh yeah
Amanda this is my stepdad mark how long
are you here Amanda
my mom's gonna pick me up around
midnight midnight slate for us I'll call
your mom she can come pick you up now
she's busy doing what chemotherapy I
don't have any feelings ever and that
doesn't necessarily make me a bad person
just means I have to work a little
harder to be good I'm sending you to
boarding school after that you're off my
payroll
you ain't him you despise him
hi maybe you can't go in with him like
that I'm fine it's not gonna have to
stand here all day like a robot
repeating myself I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine everything by just killing
him how would you what the hell is he
even doing it I am providing you all
with early drug experiences that you
will forever cherish what the hell are
you we have a business proposition for
you you've got a gun yes I have a gun
you don't know or I come for question
sir a man you have no idea I couldn't
think you'd bring it here hold it no
thanks anyway
you cannot hesitate the only thing worse
is being incompetent or being unkind or
being evil is being indecisive okay
shall we
what am I gonna tell my dad wear a hat
we're keeping this by the way
you